[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Слобожанщина,
Харків]
По-перше, скажу,
що це у нас голова повітряного патруля.
Це от — погони, які вказують, що він пілот.
[Станіслав Зубар
Пілот]
Усі пілоти повинні мати ось такі...
Тобто «4» — це командир повітряного судна.
Оскільки ми не просто цивільна авіація,
у нас ще така от емблемка
як у авіації Української Народної Республіки.
Такі погони були
[Юрій Покусай
Пілот]
Таким чином, така «спадковість поколінь».
Хочу вам сказати про історію,
я просто викладаю історію авіації кадетам.
У Харкові був Харківсько-Полтавський
окремий авіаційний загін,
який дуже ефективно воював з бандами більшовицькими, які сунули на Україну.
У Харкові були дуже міцні історії.
Історії Української Народної Республіки і
авіації Української Народної Республіки.
Річ у тому, що 70 років, за часів СРСР,
ця історія знищувалась.
Усі бажали знищити цю інформацію,
таку ж як і про Голодомор.
Інформацію цю заперечували.
«Цього немає» і так далі.
У Харкові також дуже багато було авіаторів
за часів Української Народної Республіки.
От ми коли літаємо, от сьогодні наприклад,
ми летіли і я кажу: «Ви розумієте,
це те саме небо, в якому літали
ті самі пілоти 100 років тому».
Ну правда, трошки вже Харків змінився.
Але історію треба свою пам’ятати.
Ідея?
Дуже просто...
Коли розпочалася збройна агресія.
Це знаєте, як 2014 рік нас змінив усіх.
Тобто коли ми побачили,
що треба захищати свою державу,
треба бути корисним
своїй державі таким чином.
У 14 році всі зрозуміли,
що ось цей час прийшов.
Коли просто сидіти осторонь і
дивитись не вийде, неможливо.
Кожен обирав для себе, де бути
і що робити.
От ми вибрали такий шлях.
Усі розуміли, що треба захищати.
Тут багато розмовляти не треба було.
Треба захищати від «русского міра».
От так кажуть: «русскій мір = війна».
Якщо твій друг з Маріуполя може
розказати, що то таке,
то те ж саме було і в Харкові.
Але, на щастя, Харків відстояли.
Почалося все з допомоги армії,
із захисту, з Євромайдану.
А все виросло в цивільний повітряний патруль.
Виникла така ідея: об’єднати пілотів,
які готові своєю технікою, своїми знаннями
надавати підтримку збройним силам,
іншим силовим структурам, державі
та її громадянам.
Тобто повністю за аналогією із цивільним
повітряним патрулем Сполучених Штатів,
був створений перший
добровольчий авіаційний загін,
в який увійшли відповідні льотчики на своїй техніці.
Починаючи з 2014 року це було
і сприяння Збройним Силам України,
і Службі Безпеки України
у подоланні терористичної загрози,
сприяння аеро-медичній евакуації.
В 2016 році на базі першого
добровольчого авіаційного загону
був створений цивільний повітряний патруль.
Це громадське формування,
яке об'єднує пілотів, зокрема приватних,
професійних пілотів,
які літають в авіакомпаніях.
Головне завдання — це те, що люди
готові своїми знаннями,
своєю технікою допомагати рідній державі.
Відповідно до наших статутних завдань,
у нас є чотири основні напрями діяльності:
по-перше, це сприяння Збройним Силам,
Службі Безпеки України,
Національній поліції
щодо виконання поставлених завдань
із захисту нашої території.
Відповідний меморандум у нас підписаний
з авіацією державної прикордонної служби
про спільну діяльність, тобто сприяння.
І нашим прикордонникам по захисту лінії державного кордону.
Другий напрям діяльності — це сприяння
Державній службі надзвичайних ситуацій
в подоланні наслідків якихось
техногенних катастроф, аварій і так далі.
Третій напрям — це сприяння центрам
екстреної медичної допомоги
в якнайшвидшій доставці постраждалих,
поранених в лікувальні заклади.
Тобто в тому разі, якщо життю
пацієнта є якась загроза,
то вилітає наш літак та
доставляє в якнайкоротший термін
пацієнта до лікувального закладу.
І четвертий напрям діяльності —
це національно-патріотичне виховання
нашої молоді.
У нас в організації функціонує авіаційний
навчальний кадетський центр.
Точно так, як в Сполучених Штатів, до речі,
в них також є кадетська програма.
Набір з 12 років в нашому кадетському центрі.
Тобто у нас зараз близько 100 вихованців.
Щиро віримо, що це майбутні пілоти.
У складі нашої організації чотири
оперативні командування,
які територіально розташовані
в Києві, Одесі, Львові, Харкові.
Також у Харкові безпосередньо є
Департамент авіації спеціального призначення,
який створений у складі нашої організації
з метою виконання авіаційних завдань.
У середньому у нас кожен день,
якщо казати по Дніпру, —
у нас постійно стоїть на чергуванні два літаки,
Києвом чергує у нас два літаки,
у Сумах також є.
Тобто у нас у регіонах є літаки,
що можуть виконувати завдання.
Також і Херсон, і Одеса, і Миколаїв.
Ну, в Харкові є 5 літаків у нас.
Телефонує нам диспетчер Центру екстреної
медичної допомоги та медицини катастроф,
що треба летіти.
Заїжджає швидка: лікар швидкої допомоги,
анестезіолог, сідає в літак.
Якщо говорити про таймінг: Лозова...
Ми проводили минулого тижня аеро-медичну
евакуацію дитини звідти.
Долетіли туди за 40 хвилин.
В одному напрямку йде автомобіль швидкої — 4 години
і чотири в зворотному.
То 8 годин буде таймінг, так?
У нас — півтори години.
Дитину завантажили в літак,
евакуювали його без батьків.
Тільки лікар-анестезіолог на борту.
А це ж хлопець 11 років.
Він коли побачив літак:
«Вау, супер! Я вже виздоровів,
мені вже цікаво все».
Літак має терапевтичний ефект на дітей.
Одного разу ми евакуювали 5-річного хлопчика.
До речі, також з Лозової.
Ярік — Ярослав. І коли ми його завантажили
до літака, ми з мамою його евакуювали,
він так подивився і каже:
«Тепер я найкрутіший Ярік у всій Лозовій».
Тож це факт! Найкрутіший Ярік у всій Лозовій.
А взагалі ви знаєте, таке почуття,
коли ти вперше рятуєш життя людини…
От пам’ятаю свій перший аеро-медичний виліт.
Це була дитина п’ятирічна з черепно-мозковою
травмою, у віддалених районах.
Й оцей підйом, ці емоції,
коли ти врятував людське життя...
Це просто супер!
Це словами не передати.
Це класно!
От тому й приходять пілоти,
які нам допомагають.
Коли ми прилітаємо на аеродроми
такі віддалені, мені що цікаво:
люди коли бачать літак, то два фактори:
перший, що це літак прилетів
і хтось цього взагалі не чекає.
Прилетів літак. Як прилетів літак?
Прилетів літак!
Тобто у людей з’являється гордість
і за нашу державу, і за наше суспільство.
І, знаєте, не все так погано в нашій державі.
Загалом, коли мені деякі опоненти говорять:
«От, держава не допомагає… Це держава».
Ви знаєте, держава — це абстрактна річ,
а що – ми не держава?
Ми є держава.
Ми всі є держава.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Монтажерка
Юлія Рублевська]
[Музика
Blooms Corda, Tik Tu, Masbeing]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]